hey guys how's it going we are at
Nemacolin Woodlands today and we're
going to be celebrating Brie's birthday
because I missed her actual birthday
we're about to go on some sort of a
train ride who thought it was like a
different type of train but it's like an
actual little you'll see here's the
train it's louise african train this is
gonna be pretty fun look how cute looks
like your pic and ivories already
started with you touch it think again
please touch yeah touch it you to touch
Bree can you touch it it's just sorry
I'm sorry was that demonic hello are you
ugly bird ugly bird pretty bird or ugly
bird I hear breathing what's up Bri what
Bri oh wait wait
this is Louie Louie I hope you have air
conditioning in there
Meopta day so you're not Louie this is
Louie
[Music]
I'm sorry we get to feed them you get
the feeding look at their chili
he's like I'm king of a hill careful
animals they bite I hope I'm not
allergic to everything so your honestly
they probably yeah
[Music]
just look at it I mean it's still it's
still connected
someone needs to cut that cord I'm a
little stinky side but they've been
smelling me for a little bit longer
we're about to go see the Bears I
believe the rumor has it they were able
to feed them marshmallow
[Music]
he's a Himalayan black bear he's not
native North America she'll pop it okay
just there you go that's Joe let's go
all right if you go on the other side
the cage will feed you one no don't let
don't put another one that is Brio eat
it
[Music]
so they're excellent plotters about to
find a snack shop which I can't find I
think that if they're a little thing a
fella building knack shop breakfasts
7:00 a.m. to 11:00 lunch love we should
want a snack though close no snack can
you believe that site that we saw the
closed snack shop I know what he's going
where we are no Genesis just realized I
didn't end my vlog we ended up going to
the casino and not doing so well and now
I'm at home playing it intended yes like
a movie so I'll see you guys my next
vlog hi
[Music]